Robert McNamara was Secretary of Defense
and for reasons I still don't understand
to this day he wrote out a hundred
questions almost all of which were about
current Vietnam issues politically
political issues and attacks on the
administration and there were about ten
or so questions that were of historical
nature and I was at that time director
of policy planning in the Pentagon and I
was also given this assignment and said
you know it's hard to answer all these
current policy questions without delving
into the history of them so they said
dad go get yourself six people and work
for the summer and answer the questions
well we got into the archives to started
to answer the questions and I think all
of us felt a very bright group of people
that this was an opportunity to try to
do a quick history so we outlined a
whole bunch of studies that we thought
needed to be done and the next order
from McNamara was all right thank you
thank you another six months and get it
all done that answer the questions and
that turned into almost a two-year
effort that I oversaw at the same time I
remain director of policy planning where
we had access to government documents
not all of the government documents but
I would say in 85 90 percent and we
wrote a history based on those documents
which were then leaked to the New York
Times and the other papers and became
known as the Pentagon Papers
I think that a lot most of what's been
written about Pentagon Papers just isn't
true they say that the Pentagon Papers
show that history of the United States
in Vietnam is the story of lying that's
what the Pentagon Papers prove our
leaders lied to us there was lying that
went on from time to time to be sure but
by and large we got involved in Vietnam
because that's what we believed we
believed in the domino theory we
believed that certain nations were lost
that would lead to the communism will
lead to the loss of other nations it's
what happened with Hitler and Hirohito
in World War two they took little
Nations and then bigger nations and we
got involved in World War two
so we believed in domino theory my whole
generation was raised on the domino
theory and it was believed at the time
including by me that Vietnam was kind of
the testing ground the confrontation
between east and west so we fought there
principally for that reason and it was
supported by domestic politics and it
was supported by the arrogance of power
as I write in my new book